ومن المفاجات للبعض ايضا في المونديال
الفوز فريق اليابان على المانيا بهدفين
مقابل هدف الفريق الالماني كان ضمن
المرشحين الفوز بهذه البطوله سالنا الناس
عن رايهم في مباراه الامس متابعه
اليابان احسن بالدفاع بس يعني ما بعرف شو
احكي انا بشجع على المانيا بس مش عارف
حلوه بس انه المانيا
بصراحه
اليوم اثنين واحد من اليابان والشاب
الياباني
الفوز بصراحه انا كنت اشجع المنتخب
الالماني وكنت اتمنى انه المنتخب الالماني
يفوز بس كانت مباراه بمعنى الكلمه مباراه
قيم وحاميه جدا جدا مع المانيا بصراحه بس
كاس العالم هذا بصراحه كله شكله غير متوقع
يعني زي امبارح السعوديه والارجنتين
بصراحه مباراه اليوم كانت كثير قويه
ويعني بصراحه انا كنت مع المانيا وما
توقعت الخساره ليش الحكي بالشوط الاول
صراحه المانيا كانوا ضاغطيين وبرضو
اليابان كانوا ضاغطين بس بالشوط الثاني
صراحه
وكان في شويه اغلاط باللعب وكان في تردد
فما حبيت هذا الشيء الماني انا زعلت منكم
انا ويميس بس كانت جيم حلوه وان شاء الله
يعني اللي جاي احلى